what is up everybody it's an iMac here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime newscast
the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments now
our first piece of news for this week
has some very sad news this week we
learned that high school of the Dead
creator or mangaka dice k sato actually
passed away at the age of 52 as a result
of heart disease this is such a tragedy
on a human level that a talented artist
would die at such a young age and of
course it's very sad news for fans of
highschool of the dead wanted to see the
series continue in the future our
sincere condolences to the family of
Daisuke Sato and to all the fans of his
work you might have noticed that at the
beginning of all of our weekly anime
newscast we feature a short clip from
the high school of the dead anime
opening for this week as a sign of
respect I decided to keep the intro
silent in other news a new no game no
life anime film has just been announced
it will be released on July fifteenth of
this year and new character designs and
a short preview have just been released
this is certainly great news for fans of
no game no life but it is important to
note that so far it appears that this
new film is not going to feature Sora m0
the main characters from the anime
instead it's going to feature different
characters that appear in the back story
chapter in volume 6 of the light novel
at any rate let me know if you're
excited for this film down below and i
will leave the link for the full preview
in the description in code geass sequel
news just the other day thanks to a
heads up from anime world we actually
found a new pv teaser ad for the code
geass sequel this ad appeared at the
code geass booth at the anime japan 2017
anime event and someone appears to have
simply recorded it on their phone and
that posted it on their twitter account
at first i thought the ad was posted at
a subway station or a train station or
something like that because we see
people just walking by randomly going in
different directions however it appears
that it was at an actual anime event
thanks to Otaru for correcting me on
this I just love being corrected by you
at arrow and if you want
see a special video we made where we
analyze this PV and look for potential
clues for season 3 the link is in the
description the ghost in the shell live
action adaptation is hitting theaters
this Friday March 31st and to mark the
occasion I'm actually working on a new
video that is going to be talking all
about the ghost in the shell franchise
as anime fans we are all really curious
to see how this adaptation will turn out
but before this movie has even come out
there are already rumors about the 1988
classic Akira anime film being adapted
by Hollywood as well crunchyroll is
reporting that Warner Brothers is trying
to find a director to direct the ocular
adaptation however we have gotten these
kinds of rumors before about Akira so I
don't want to rush to judgment will see
if anything comes out of it we will let
you know and do you think that an ocular
live-action adaptation would be a good
idea let me know in the comments and
since I mentioned ghost in the shell
black critic guy actually uploaded a
review this week for the 1995 original
animated film ghost in the shell and yes
he did use this opportunity to take his
shirt off again so for that alone be
sure to check it out last week a quick
teaser was released for the Death Note
netflix live-action adaptation and i
made a short video talking about my
views about this teaser you can check
that out in the description I know a
whole bunch of anime youtubers made a
video on this topic I know black critic
guy made a video and Aki Darius made a
video as well I thought okies video was
really good i agree with a lot of what
you had to say so be sure to check that
out the link is in the description
attack on titan season 2 is set to
premiere this saturday April first
hopefully and this week Funimation
uploaded to their YouTube channel on
interview with Hajime isayama the
original creator of attack on Titan if
you're a fan of attack on titan and
you're just loving the hype right now be
sure to check out that interview and my
favorite AMV for this week was an ambi
called boom-lay by king AMV this video
features a whole bunch of awesome anime
put together into a great AMV it has
good and log on Fullmetal Alchemist
Brotherhood
darker than black some of my favorite
anime so I really enjoyed it and I
definitely recommend it and that is it
for this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]